doesn't this prove that what we're doing
up there is absolutely insane top gun
maverick is filled with incredible
stunts which of course you know by now
aren't cgi but did you know the stunts
were so dangerous they even had the real
aviators scared that's what topkin's
been doing for years making grown men
cry number one how could anybody say no
to tom cruise cruz is a licensed pilot
and he's flown a p-51 propeller-driven
fighter plane and some helicopters but
the navy denied him permission to fly an
f-18 fighter jet so that wasn't him
piloting the crazy stunts he was in the
back seat actually all of the actors
were and were doing their lines at the
same time director joseph kaczynski said
probably the most dangerous and daring
is in the middle of the film where
maverick flies the course to prove the
mission can be flown for that sequence
tom went through the real top gun
low-level training course at less than
50 feet above the ground at 500 miles
per hour the plane was so close to the
ground that it was stirring up dust and
making the cameras on the ground shake
aerial coordinator kevin larosa ii said
when you see them flying low over
terrain in between valleys dogfighting
that's really our cast
number two mountain stunts are stunning
unfortunately miles teller was stunned
in a different way when they go over a
mountain peak they don't go over like
this as soon as they get to the top they
go inverted well teller didn't strap
himself in tight enough and was lifted
out of his seat when the jet inverted he
hit his head against the canopy and that
shot made it into the final cut of the
film it's in the movie actually i hit my
head on the canopy and i thought it was
an unusable take not that they go
looking for mistakes to happen but when
they do they're unrepeatable gold
number three imagine having allergies
and being burned by tom cruise at the
same time poor teller wasn't having a
great time on set like sure flying in
airplanes is awesome but between hitting
his head and now blood poisoning he just
can't catch a break teller says we
landed and i'm just like man i'm not
feeling too good i was really hot and i
just started itching like crazy so i get
out of the jet and i'm just covered in
hives like head to toe instantly i go to
a doctor i do like a blood analysis this
that whatever i'm in an oatmeal bath at
night so he goes to tell crews about his
experience well tom it turns out
i have jet fuel in my blood and cruz's
response is
legendary tom just goes yeah i was born
with a kid it wasn't just jet fuel
though he also had flame retardant and
pesticides in his blood that flame
retardant should help with that sick
burn though number four on top of blood
poisoning and whacking his head teller
also wet himself okay not really but he
did have one moment in the f-18 hornet
jet where he thought he was a goner he
admitted there was a sequence where we
were heading straight towards the ground
and you do what's called a max g pull-up
you're heading down and at the last
second you yank up and it's really tough
for the pilot it's something they train
in all the time but it was the first
time we'd done a maneuver like that and
i completely stopped acting i looked at
the ground and thought this wasn't going
to end well for me
number five it's safe to say any stunt
in a plane is dangerous but this one is
pretty nerve-wracking they were actually
flying in the mountains with very little
room for error i mean the mountains are
less than 100 feet off each wing tip and
there's cloud cover sometimes too
number six just one of the many times
the actors would lose their lunch was
the upside-down shots but monica barbaro
was a natural at that due to her dance
training saying there was a funny moment
where a couple of the guys were saying
they hated going upside down and i was
like i've been going upside down forever
i would do handstands before flights it
helped me control some of the weird
feelings of blood rushing to spaces you
don't usually want it to number 7.
during monica's callback audition she
did a little oopsy and lied to the
director upon being asked if she was a
strong swimmer he's like can you swim i
was like yeah he was like you're a
comfortable swimmer i was like yeah you
know lying they all did a ton of swim
training just in case they needed to
eject over water but this is next level
water training the actors were being
pushed off a high rise and fell into a
pool and had to unstrap their parachutes
and there's one drill where the wind was
pushing the parachute across the water
man was monica ever in over her head
luckily she got to spend a ton of extra
time in the water training number eight
just imagine if this movie didn't get
made because tom couldn't be bothered to
put a helmet on we know it's a dorky
thought but seriously for somebody who's
so into health and safety on a plane he
kinda lets all that fly out the window
when it comes to his motorbike maybe
that's because bikes don't have windows
number nine the roof isn't on fire but
it isn't attached either in the opening
scene maverick flies over ed harris and
it rips the roof off of the shack thanks
to the force of the jet's takeoff watch
it rips the roof off the guard shack
that was not planned director kozinski
knew at that moment that there was no
need to rebuild the set because that
take was the only one they needed that
was a one-take thing where we destroyed
the set and that's the only shot we got
well that could have been a whole lot
more dangerous but luckily the roof
didn't fly too far
number 10. you've got to be prepared for
things to go wrong that's the difference
between an amateur and a pro so they did
a controlled stall where they turn off
the engine and you're free falling it
got pretty real pretty quick to be
honest with you number 11. training is
just controlled danger boot camp
training happened with the navy and the
top gun school to formulate how to shoot
the movie practically the actors started
out flying in single-engine airplanes to
build out their spatial awareness inside
the aircraft next they went in the l-39
and went and flew aerobatics to feel
what it's like in a jet tom cruise
developed the flight training program
that the actors needed to go through so
he designed a program that would get
them as ready as they could be the boot
camp took three months and the actors
had to develop skills in underwater
evacuation aerial aviation and flight
one thing in particular made these
flying scenes dangerous and that's the
dynamic pressure of the g-force that can
cause a lack of blood supply and make
pilots go unconscious kevin said i like
to attribute it to something similar to
muscle memory so it's a tolerance that
you build up and that's what paramount
and crews made with this pilot training
program to acclimate them and build up
the g-tolerance and build up their
fatigue levels without that there
wouldn't have been a movie in the
original top gun a stunt pilot named art
shoal fatefully plunged into the pacific
ocean after his pitts s2 camera plane
failed to recover from a spin he
suffered the same fate as the character
goose so when you're filming a sequel
with a history like that you'd better
take every precaution number 12 lots of
injuries sweat and vomit went into the
making of top gun actually tom cruise
was all too familiar with that geforce
feeling because in the first movie he
vomited in his helmet which is most
definitely why he did the boot camp
every minute of extreme motion sickness
while filming is money wasted before
cruz signed on to star in the original
top gun he took a test flight in a jet
he was flying at 6.5 g's and felt the
blood drain from his head he vomited in
his fighter pilot mask and he learned
from that to squeeze his thighs and abs
to stay conscious kevin said there's no
pulling over on the side of the road
when you're in a 50 000 pound fa-18
doing 500 knots in a canyon you're in it
let's be real pretty much everybody
except for the dancer vomited at least
once in the original movie and in the
sequel top gun maverick outdid itself
truly there were a ton of close calls
but we're just glad no one was injured
too bad for the sequel would you set
foot in an f-18 fighter jet given the
risks passenger or pilot let us know in
the comments and thanks for hanging out
with us here at the things